movie opens essentially in the third act
after Chris Hemsworth has basically been
shot and he is doing very bad and that's
how the film opens so was it always
going to open like that or did you have
that's always the open
no that was that was something we found
in the editing room that the film
originally the script opened with the
rescue it opened with the scene with
rake in the room with the kidnappers and
that that opening fight that you see in
the apartment and it was then it was
crosscut kind of you'd do that and then
you go back to you know real time where
he's driving with the kids so it was an
interesting playing with time and then
when we when we laid that out we just
found that it was a little bit it didn't
work as well as a linear store is
following the logic the linear story
with a little bit of a you know tease as
to where we're going because we played
it and just to be perfectly honest if we
if it was a theatrical release and you
had a literally a captive audience we
probably would have started the movie
with the kids story we probably we
wouldn't they used that original bit
with hims worth on the bridge but
because you know his Netflix and you've
got Chris Hemsworth on the poster and if
you don't give them Chris Hemsworth in
the first you know five ten minutes I'm
gonna switch the channel they're gonna
change it and watch something else
so we're like we you know how do we we
got to keep them we got to keep people
invested and watching and so then we you
know came up with the idea to let's
let's do a little bit of show people
where we're going and then you know
hopefully they'll come along for the
ride to see how we got there
I know I've been waiting to talk to you
about this since I saw the film which is
I want to talk about the ending circle
so I've watched the film twice and there
you know the beginning of your the
beginning of the film you have Chris
Hemsworth jumping in the water he's
underwater is basically meditating if
you will I think about his life and it
shows that his character under the water
cut to the end of the film we have the
kid in the water submerged and he's
thinking he comes up and we and we look
in the background behind him you can see
the silhouette of what looks like Chris
Hemsworth so I'm of the opinion there's
one of three answers see 100% worth is
his character survived and is teaching
the kid his techniques - the kid has
learned everything to know about the
person who saved his life and his
imagining Chris Hemsworth's characters
sitting there and teaching him he
learned that Chris used to do the
breathing if you will impossibility 3
it's someone who looks like Chris
Hemsworth's character who is now his
body would you care to comment on these
three things I love that I mean but
what's so great about it is those are
three valid you know opinions and what
would hopefully happen is people will be
afterwards discussing that and you get
to say like which one and you feel is
right for you because what we what we
did first I'll give you a kind of work
sorry where where and why we landed
where we did then I'll give you the
original movie handing so we we tested
we had a a version of the movie and we
tested tested it a lot and it it was not
surprising that people a lot of people
wanted to know the character to live
some people want to die it was it was
ambiguous people were like they were
torn it was almost down the middle and
we're like you know we want to appeal as
many people as possible without
compromising the integrity of the story
and so really think a pretty good
compromise is to make an ambiguous
ending to where if people on one hand
feel like the story is complete and is a
story of redemption through sacrifice
then for them it'll be you know option
either two or three it'll be where the
kid is like imagining that and then now
you go like yes I'm satisfied if you
feel like you love Tyler rake and you
love Chris
and you want a sequel and you're like oh
you know there's no way you can't kill
him that's Chris him that's Tyler right
standing there looking at you so we kind
of purposefully did not pull focus to
you know the character standing there
and in truth again that was a thing of
testing and multiple could be shot
multiple endings we shot you know a lot
of different ways to pull this off
because here's your spoiler alert for
those who there the original script and
this was my idea is that Rick does not
live he his story was complete because
he in found reason to something to keep
him alive and that he you know the his
journey was complete when he set a
danger again Shin through sacrifice that
he made the choice he was okay with that
he come to terms with his past and the
choice that he made in the present to
save this kid and if that meant you know
him dying so be it and that was you know
his journey in my mind and then a very
astute thing by you know the Netflix
Netflix president Netflix Scott Stuber
his point was well-taken and I it's
fantastic and I remember this for ever
is you know easy you got to remember the
difference between an intellectually
satisfying ending and an emotionally
satisfying ending you know is so that
and so we we struggled with that concept
of is it more emotionally satisfying
that Rick lives or that reg dies and and
truthfully a lot of people that the vote
was it's more emotionally satisfying
that he lives because it's like you know
now the kid represented gave him
something to live for and now he's
living for that so basically that what
you see in the movie is a compromise
like we because a lot of the us who were
in the original camp didn't want him to
survive a lot in the new camp did want
him to we tested it and literally down
the middle I mean I think the stats or
somewhere I remember the exact
percentage but it's it's almost right
down the middle of people who wanted to
live versus died it's really a hey we're
gonna give you the best of both worlds
we're gonna like have this ambiguous
where you can choose your own adventure
no I I listen I totally think the ending
is fantastic because I love the
ambiguous nature of it where and I
paused it last night when I rewatched it
I'm like is that comes we're standing
there trying to make it out but you got
shot it out [ __ ] you know you didn't
focus enough to be able to tell yeah and
with and that's great see that's
something that I as a filmmaker you
appreciate you know so long and that's
but that's for the right reasons because
if it was it was you going back and you
were frustrating like what them and you
were frustrated by that then you be like
ah that's not good but if you like it's
like what and you're looking more and
it's like a mystery that you're trying
to solve but in a positive way that
you're intrigued by then I think it's
great then it serves a purpose and
ambiguity works in that senora I love
the scene where and I don't remember
character names sorry where the the near
the end where the drug dealer the other
drug dealer is taking a piss and she
comes in and basically takes him out and
I love the way the shell runs on the
ground can you sort of talk about
crafting that scene and having that
she'll do what it does yeah that was
actually one of the first scenes that we
shot it was the first scene we shot with
that those two actors and so it was kind
of a feeling out process of how you know
how he wanted knowing it was gonna be
the last time we see you know coal ships
his character and and Creon to you it
was a kind of an interesting feeling out
process we had to do a lot of road
mapping of where they've come from like
what a lot of movie happens before this
but it's the first time these two people
have interacted the first time these
characters are on camera so we have a
long discussions about all that stuff
but then get what I wanted to do is you
know all think it was from like James
Bond and it's a lot of great kind of
paths bathroom scenes and what I wanted
to have kind of this homage to that but
also to the and the shell kind of
represents kind of the random nature of
you know life and death and this world
that's you know one moment that you're
up here the next minute you're like you
know you're dead on the bathroom floor
with your privates in your hands you
know it's it's like a weird thing and so
you know
never know which way like the shell is
gonna balance so that you know so it's
just kind of a little metaphor we and
visual metaphor we threw in there and
that particular shell no we didn't do it
like a hundred times to try to get it to
do the perfect thing we actually that
was a digitally placed shell in there
after the fact we knew we wanted
something like that to happen so we left
a place for it but to make it behave so
we didn't have to do it so much we saved
that for the visual effects team uh when
you think back on by the way how many
shooting days did you have for this
thing
you
we had I believe principal photography
was 58 days actually that's not a lot of
time or how much action yeah you know
it's funny it's it's it it's a bit about
it for for movies you know that I'm have
worked on in the past it's not much time
at all but for you know for a first-time
movie and it's it's a lot you know a lot
of movies get shot half the time I've
worked on movies it you know it's not a
third at that time we gotta always were
able to make our day and stay on
schedule and I think you know it's a
great job by the again the ad Department
and the the producing side of things to
keep everything running smoothly and we
we didn't you know we didn't run over we
got we got it done and we had to go back
to pick up some stuff but it wasn't
nothing that was nothing was left
unlocked of what we plan to shoot um you
have there's a lot of action set pieces
in this and I'm just curious how much
are you able to how much are you and
Chris like sort of plotting out all
these action set pieces before stepping
on set on day one and how much of what
we see on screen is being figured out
during the shoot yeah I say because
there's so much action and the schedule
is pretty tight for this most of what we
did we knew what we were doing and you
know we had a if not exactly what we
wanted a very good blueprint of what we
needed to do for example that with the
Warner that in the twelve shot 12-minute
one shot we we went on I mean
we've started the planning process of
that by three four months ahead of time
we went on I think seven different tech
Scouts which normally like in the
process you get one maybe two we went on
seven different times where we took the
entire crew and walk through this
sequence start to finish you know took
us whatever six eight hours there's a
full day of like this is what we did so
everybody knew what we were doing we
bring the stunt team they would you know
go through all the action so everybody
was very so what we're doing this we
can't you know nobody can crap service
can't be set up over there were cameras
gonna be here it was very well laid out
you know and then
you get there on the day and you know
things that for whatever reason you know
you were her stood in a hotel you know
conference room because the location was
it wasn't ready because it was you know
being painted or whatnot and so you kind
of you mocked up the space but it wasn't
exactly right now the the hallway is
much more narrow than we thought it was
so now you have to change now it can't
be this big spinning move that we had
planned now you got to change it so
there was a lot of that fitting the
choreography and the design of the
action to to work better in the space
but we did know we learn making things
up as we got there hey this looks cool
what should we do here we definitely had
a very good idea of what we were doing
but the part of that to me the reason we
put so much time in prep is it gives you
the confidence to show up on a set and
look for something better because the
few the worst-case scenario is you you
shoot exactly what you had planned and
great you go home and you got something
but if you can get there and you have
that in your back pocket for me at least
it gives me the freedom to look around
and say hey what can I add what can I
make better knowing that I have this set
you know this plan in my back pocket and
so we a lot of that happen in the the
tenement fight the first time that Rick
lets loose and when he shoves the guy's
head onto a rake spoiler alert things
like that came out of spontaneity in the
moment like we we had anything that we
wanted and and we got it and it just me
and looking through dailies you know
doesn't quite have the same impact that
I wanted to have and then you got to do
some horse trading you're like well we
can you know have we can take a day away
from this sequence to give you another
day to really get what you wanted there
and you're like is it worth it yes I'll
do it because it's the first time we see
him do this fight you make changes and
compromises somewhere else and go
alright I need an extra day here to make
it work and it's that's just filmmaking
you know you're constantly making
compromises and changes and trying to
you know make it all work to the best of
your ability